okay we do have some important breaking
news today
about the hopefully forthcoming
coronavirus vaccine
as many of you know donald trump has put
many political eggs
in the basket of being able to announce
a coronavirus vaccine before election
day
and donald trump has for a while now
been talking about could be mid-october
could be even sooner
and remember that this was never going
to be a standard fda approval for the
vaccine the hope was what trump was
counting on
was an emergency use authorization from
the fda now at its core
from the starting point an eua
is already not as rigorous of a process
as a full approval for a vaccine but
even the possibility of the emergency
use authorization now
is significantly less likely because the
fda announced just hours ago
that it's going to be tightening up the
authorization standards for vaccine
emergency use making it very
unlikely that donald trump is going to
get this announcement before election
day now this matters for two reasons
first of all this matters from a public
health standpoint
we need a vaccine and it's going to be
longer than some hoped for the eua
now the counterpoint is we all knew
that trump wanted to announce the eua
even though
the vaccine doses were never really
going to be available
widely in 2020 so this may not really
change
when the average person will get the
vaccine it's merely going to change
donald trump getting to announce it
before the election
and that's why there's a big political
implication here
donald trump was counting on being
buoyed
in the polls by being able to say we got
a vaccine
now we knew all along that even if he
got the emergency
authorization in the next few weeks
before the election
it was going to be a while before
anybody could really get the vaccine any
significant number
a number of people but incredibly this
may be even more
self-inflicted damage by donald trump
because
part of the reason why the fda is now
saying
we're going to make it tougher stricter
we're going to boost transparency
part of the reason they are doing this
is because so many people have expressed
concern
that donald trump has politicized the
vaccine and
people are rightly skeptical about what
it would really mean
for an early eua from the fda if the fda
is merely under the thumb of donald
trump
the fda is going to put in place a
number of new
requirements it is going to put in place
the requirement of following
participants in these late stage
clinical trials for a median of at least
two months
starting after the second dose of the
vaccine
the predominant number of vaccines being
tested are two doses typically separated
by about 30 days
per the news times as a sign that the
vaccine works
the agency also is planning to look more
closely
at people with severe cases of
coronavirus
and looking at specifically
people in the placebo groups who got
coronavirus
and doing a lot more than what some were
hoping would be done
if you were hoping for an early approval
this is going to take time
and the agency previously said that any
vaccine would have to be at least 50
percent more effective than a placebo
so now we're hearing from all sorts of
experts including paul offit
who directs the vaccine education center
at children's hospital of philadelphia
he says quote
it's hard to imagine how an emergency
use authorization could possibly
occur before december moderna has now
said
they are unlikely to have the required
data by
uh the end of october astrazeneca
uh has had to stop their trial as
they're looking into this
serious neurological problem that
happened to a participant
in that trial um pfizer had a vaccine
which
conceivably could have been the one that
maybe in october could have gotten an
emergency use authorization but based on
the new restrictions
that is likely to be postponed now
there's another uh sort of parallel
story to this
which is that a whole bunch of the
country
still says they're not going to get a
coronavirus vaccine they will not seek
it out
and that is more trump people than biden
people people who
thanks in part to donald trump's
administration still aren't taking
coronavirus
seriously there's new data from the pew
research center which reports that the
percentage of americans who
say they would get the vaccine if it
were available today
has dropped to just about 50 percent
back in may
in that same study 72 percent
of respondents said i'd get the vaccine
now
just over 50 percent of respondents
say they would get the vaccine so
consider the insanity
of this country on the one hand trump
has been banking on announcing a vaccine
that he had no role in developing to try
to get himself reelected
on the other hand it's his followers who
disproportionately
don't plan to get the vaccine anyway
raising the question of well would the
vaccine announcement even really help
trump that much
i don't know the answer it's stunning
stuff and it doesn't seem as though
donald trump is going to
get that announcement now one other
issue to talk about
this is a broader issue and we're
looking into bringing an expert on
to ask them about it should vaccines
ever be authorized via an emergency use
authorization
anyway there are critics who say euas
are not for vaccines okay you do you get
early data that remdesseviere is working
you do an emergency use authorization
with with you know caveats and
restrictions
you get early data that dexamethasone is
reducing mortality in serious
coronavirus patients
you do an emergency use authorization
for a vaccine you don't do it
say some critics now there are others
who say
you you do want to keep an eua for a
vaccine on the table
when you have thousands of people a week
dying
if you get an efficacy signal that is
good enough and what
good enough means of course needs to be
delineated more specifically
you you consider an eua then
you need to figure out do any of the
vaccines that we actually have available
warrant an eua and that's a more
specific question to be answered
reasonable people can disagree about
that from a political standpoint
it does not appear that donald trump is
going to get it we're going to have more
on vaccination
on the david pakman show instagram
that's david pakman show
on instagram make sure you're following
us there
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video